the future is here it's just not evenly
distributed look around the world and we
know this to be true you're all here in
this room
chances are the vast majority of you got
in a regular gasoline-powered vehicle
and drove here to the venue today
however we know that in the future many
of us will be driving electric vehicles
clean electric vehicles those electric
vehicles may be using power that came
from dirty coal so how clean is that
electric vehicle well that's also
becoming a salt problem in California
today you could use a company like Solar
City to go install solar panels on your
roof that look like legitimate roofing
this isn't an eyesore it's just your
entire roof is a solar panel pretty
amazing future that's already here if
you're in California today completely
off the grid we know that today if you
go to the grocery store the vast
majority of us have this as our reality
we wait in line to check out however if
you're lucky enough to be in Seattle
near the very first Amazon go store
there is no such thing as a line there's
no such thing as a checkout you grab
what you need and you walk out the door
and sensors charge you accordingly the
future is already here it's just not
evenly distributed and this principle of
course applies to JavaScript as well the
future of JavaScript is here it's not
evenly distributed and I'm going to ask
you a few questions during this session
that's going to make that clear with
your fellow audience members so let's
get started what I'm going to talk about
is the last decade in JavaScript and
three revolutions that began in the last
decade and all three of these are still
in progress now you might think this is
a real talk through history but in fact
what you're going to see is these three
revolutions many of you have not
embraced them yet despite the fact that
they've been around for a while I find
it pretty cool that today is exactly ten
years
since Jeff Atwood coined Atwoods law
which says any application that can be
written in JavaScript will be written in
JavaScript now when outwards
said this I thought it sounded pretty
crazy despite being a guy that's really
big into JavaScript this sounded nuts
but today we live in a world where that
really is a reality think about the web
was the beginning of JavaScript we all
know that that's where it started so yes
I can write web applications using Jas
but today I can write server side apps
using node.js I can write native mobile
apps using react native using native
script using PhoneGap and I can even
write desktop apps using things like
electron it's crazy to me that my
favorite editor today is vs code and
that is written in HTML Javascript and
CSS because it uses electron my favorite
way to communicate and share gifts with
my co-workers is slack that's again
written there's some slack fans here
there we go again that is written in
plain old JavaScript using electron
pretty amazing so at what's law has come
to fruition JavaScript I like to say
it's a lot like visa it's everywhere you
want to be but it's interesting a lot of
us are JavaScript developers not because
we believe that javascript is the best
language in the world we are in
JavaScript because of where it is not
what it is
JavaScript continues to get better and I
love seeing the fact that now every year
right around June we get a new release
of JavaScript with goodness but I'm
certainly a JavaScript developer because
I can write for any platform and that's
pretty amazing so it's a really awesome
future that we have ahead with our skill
sets so anybody know what happened
January 12 2010 this was the beginning
of a key phase of the JavaScript
revolution the reusable JavaScript
revolution any guesses jQuery nope
jQuery was not then it was actually
earlier no it was drum roll drum roll
drum roll NPM NPM was announced on 2010
that was the first release of NPM pretty
big deal now at the time it didn't even
make that big of a splash because he
already had things like Bower that a lot
of people
we're using it was unclear whether who
and when people would be using NPM but
today NPM has swallowed the world as
JavaScript's de-facto package manager
and this is a key piece of the reusable
JavaScript revolution if you haven't
embraced in PM yet then you're missing
out on a lot of power now the thing is
if you rewind just two years this was
life as a developer this was how I was
spending my time if ya read some of the
script tags as part of fun but think
about the pain that we went through in
2008 just 2008 wasn't that long ago I
was dealing with all of this pain look
at what would happen oh I want to go use
someone else's work in JavaScript well
what steps would I go through well I'd
do something like this I would search
the web I'd read the docs and go install
this read the relevant install steps I
download any relevant JavaScript and CSS
I'd set up my script tags my style
references and then I'd write some
JavaScript that targets that HTML and
I'd realize it wouldn't work I mean I'd
wonder why didn't get a lot of help at
that part then I'd realized that the Dom
query that I wrote was wrong that was a
common mistake that I'd make in this era
and it still wouldn't work might fix it
still wouldn't work I'd realize that the
script order was wrong so I'd reorder a
script tag because this needs load
before this switch loads before this so
I fixed that and it still wouldn't work
then I'd read the docs some more and
realize oh okay I'm running the wrong
version of jQuery I found that buried
down in here I need to run at least this
version so I go ahead and update that
and I would repeat all of these steps to
go update jQuery there was no easy way
for me to upgrade my dependencies once
this finally worked I would typically
drink heavily and that was my 14 step
process for working with JavaScript in
2008 now if you want to stay updated
imagine this I just went through all
that work to get this going if I want to
stay updated what would I do in that
case I would repeat a lot of those steps
again very very painful and what if I
wanted to minify or bundle or test this
code nope not gonna happen not practical
in that era hardly any of us were
because it was just too hard
contrast that with today npm install lid
import the library NPM update that's
pretty cool that is vastly vastly
simpler that is worth celebrating
JavaScript doesn't have a base class
library and because of that we're seeing
NPM grow at an amazing rate NPM
effectively has filled in this gap and
it becomes growth has been unprecedented
unprecedent you look at these lines here
you want to guess which one is NPM come
on y'all you're supposed to be the one
on the top it's kind of baiting you
there look at this so this number down
here this green line down here that is
dot Nets package manager which is nougat
they add 66 packages per day how about
Java's 139 per day
NPM almost 500 packages are added every
single day to NPM by the end of the day
another 500 things are out there I mean
that is amazing that's amazing unless
you factor in sturgeons law it's always
a caveat with growth we I don't want to
pick on anybody but now I will say I
think sturgeon was a bit of a pessimist
because my take is even if sturgeons law
is true this is also true I mean more is
better ten percent of that crap is good
so that's so wind yes I know I'm a child
but this is my this is my justification
now I I really think this is a
glass-half-full mentality when you have
that sort of view it's a bit of a first
world problem kind of complaint oh no I
can't keep up with all this awesome free
stuff that people keep building for me
I mean life as a JavaScript developer
when we talk about JavaScript fatigue we
sound a little it's hard to have a lot
of sympathy for us it's a bit like going
to a family reunion and complaining
about how your inbox is full of
recruiter emails oh another recruiter
wanting me to interview it's hard being
a developer your family will do not say
this at a family reunion you think
you're crazy
so we're in a great place as JavaScript
developers and my point is this
the npm allows us to write our code once
and then reuse it it's a very simple
idea so a question for the audience
we're gonna go through this cadence
through this talk question for you
how many of you are using NPM packages
today so that is probably 70% of the
room very good but I have a more
interesting question I was expecting the
majority of you to say that you do how
about this how many of you will say my
team has published in NPM packages my
team or my company that's about ten
fifteen percent of the room although a
noisy one whoo yes we're excited about
this so look at this everybody put your
hands back up if you have published an
NPM package and Zack you're partying
back there that's cool so look around
the room guys the future is here it's
just not evenly distributed I believe
that if I came back here in a couple
years we would see the vast majority of
hands up so ask yourself do I want to
join the revolution because it is here
now what what I share is a demo that
shows how my team works with NPM
packages my team maintains an NPM
package called fusion the fusions of
framework that we use for doing react
development and Cox Automotive it adds
many opinions in on exactly how we want
to do react development so if I click
over here I can go to our github
repository and you can see that this NPM
package of course has a package JSON and
what makes this package interesting is
all the dependencies that it holds
inside our applications have a single
dependency which is fusion but behind
the scenes starting here at mine 27 and
scrolling down these are all the
dependencies that we're actually using
to put our applications to work so
developers don't have to make decisions
on webpack or babel or what react
dependencies they should be pulling in
they just leverage all of these packages
which are built in diffusion we also
include some build scripts that start
the application that configure our tests
and that perform the production build
we've also added some interesting
extensions now behind the scenes we're
actually using create react app but
we've added a number of opinions on top
to get this done but through the power
of this single NPM package when we
deploy applications this is the up
dependency that our applications take on
and in that way when we change
directions when we need to do bug fixes
or enhancements to our build process or
deployments upgrade dependencies people
have a single NPM package that they can
update as necessary so that is the key
point at the end we have at this point
published at least a half dozen
applications using a single NPM package
that we call fusion so those
applications you go into the package
JSON you know what you find there one
dependency because we've decided as a
company that will bundle up all of our
dependencies behind the scene it's about
75 NPM packages a number of build
scripts all of that is contained through
the power of NPM so I'd encourage you to
consider that pattern so that was the
first revolution which is the package
revolution this is the very foundation
of the reusable JavaScript revolution
that I'm talking about today so you need
to have accepted that before you move on
to phase 2 phase 2 of the reusable
JavaScript revolution I call starter
kits or I also like to call this part do
so if you were coding back in the day
jQuery versus mootools versus prototype
j/s which I did there was a funny site
called vanilla Jas and you would go out
to vanilla Jas and build your own custom
download you could select things like
ajax event system functions as
first-class objects do regular
expressions i want those in an array
library that sounds handy and then I
could build a custom download of all
these features in this vanilla Jas
library and when I opened it in my
editor what I would see is an empty file
do you get the punchline vanilla Jas is
using the platform and if you went
through the vanilla GS website what they
would do is contrast the performance of
plain vanilla Jas versus using jQuery or
mootools and they would point out
vanilla J's was not surprisingly faster
because it removed a layer of
abstraction and this was funny at the
time and caught some level of attention
however I believe that vanilla GIS is
malpractice and I believe that because
today as developers if we're not
leveraging each other's work we are
wasting time we are reinventing the
wheel we should be standing on the
shoulders of giants and so many of us in
here have done good work see today
here's the story so many of us are
expecting to publish an application to
the web with a single minified bundle
maybe tree shakin maybe that bundle is
split in ways so that it loads from page
to page that's not trivial you want
things like explicit dependencies you
want it to be Mart modular minified
transpiled linton tested you want an
automated build and you want automated
updates
I believe that file new project is
malpractice and in my organization we do
not do file new project when we start
from scratch we are starting from a
foundation with literally over 75
different opinions baked into it it is a
huge number of opinions that we have
think about some of the decisions that
you make if you're gonna file new
project right now as a JavaScript
developer you as a team need to decide
what editor are we going to use and how
we standardize that configuration of
tabs versus spaces line endings and as
such what NPM package or I should say
what package manager are we going to use
because NPM isn't the only one but it's
a pretty logical choice what development
web server will we use what automation
approach what transpiler what bundler
what linter how about automated testing
we need to choose a framework an
assertion library helper libraries where
to run our tests when to run them and
where to place these files we need to
choose a CI server if we're making HTTP
calls Ajax that sort of thing we need to
choose an HTTP call approach in fact if
I lay all this out on a slide it's very
difficult to fit it all and here's
what's interesting you're gonna watch
all these decisions fly by you here but
ask yourself this if you did a file new
project would you remember to ask
yourself these question
would you remember all of these concerns
because as a group in here we know that
testing is important we know that
minification and bundling and
transpiling
are all important as JavaScript
developers but it's really easy for a
lot of these decisions to hit the floor
it's easy to accidentally end up in
production in a bad state if you don't
automate it away so again I say vanilla
JavaScript today is malpractice file new
project is malpractice start from
something more opinionated and so what
I'm driven by is a level of
dissatisfaction with the current state
of affairs in JavaScript I can't get no
satisfaction
so here's where's what I'm dissatisfied
with rework I don't want to start from
scratch when I'm starting a new project
I don't want a tedious setup just so I
can get to a HelloWorld wiring up
transpiling and bundling and
minification all of these things is
really tricky and I end up repeating
mistakes how about this you read a blog
post and this blog post goes oh man this
is something I have to remember to do on
my next project but how do you remember
to do that later the way that you do
that is to codify your opinions the
solution that I am suggesting here is to
codify your opinions now one way that
you can codify your opinions is through
a checklist if you've ever had the book
checklist manifesto I highly recommend
this to developers it's not a technical
book but what it drives home is the
benefits of writing down what you need
to do see the checklist manifesto tells
an interesting story about doctors we as
developers we don't like checklist
because we feel like I'm a professional
I don't need a checklist I know what to
do off the top of my head but doctors
have been found that to need a checklist
there was a study that found this you go
in you have the nurses ask the doctors
the steps that they need to perform
before they cut a hole in your body and
run a tube into it they're gonna run a
lion into you you have to make sure that
they sit down they wash their hands
properly that they make the incision
properly they cover their hands and
gloves it's not very many steps but as a
doctor in the heat of the moment it's
really easy to forget a step and what
they found was a percentage of the time
that happened and what happens in that
case is people die people die when you
miss
step now thankfully lives generally
aren't in our hands but increasingly
that is happening in software too they
saw dramatic results by creating
checklists what they saw was the 10 day
line infection rate fell from 11% to
zero because how could you miss it if
you do the proper steps
people don't get infections because you
have protected yourself from it
the checklist prevented 43 infections
eight deaths and two million dollars in
costs
so in summary doctors know what to do
but it's easy to overlook a step and in
the same way we as developers also know
what to do but I showed you that slide
deck there were probably everything on
that slide deck you thought yeah I'm
generally familiar with that but do you
ask yourself those 40 questions every
time you start a new JavaScript project
have you asked yourself that about your
existing project today probably not so
on my team we have honored this
checklist idea we've created a file
called pull request template MD here's a
little pro tip if you use github create
a file with this name and every time
somebody creates a pull request it will
generate this within the pull request so
that way all of our pull requests have
our code review checklist right there
inside of it automatically that's us
embracing the checklist manifesto so
that we make sure we don't skip a step
however you're a developer so an even
better idea than this is to automate it
strive to automate and I think this is a
really important principle that the more
things that you can take for granted the
better off you are Society advances as
we can take things for granted the fact
that we came here today and we could
take for granted that these lights would
be on that my computer would be charged
up that I could get in a car and drive
here that's really important in the same
way as developers we need to increase
the list of things that we can take for
granted see on my team there's a long
list of things that we just don't think
about anymore my team knows that they
can use the latest version of JavaScript
they know that it will just magically
get transpiled they don't have to think
about it in any way they know that every
time that they hit save the tests will
run automatically and when we push code
it will end up running on the CI server
and we'll know if any tests have failed
we know in our code reviews that our
code reviews go really fast now because
most of the things that we look for are
caught by linters and
of manually on a case-by-case basis we
know that when we get to production
we'll be able to use source maps to
debug our code even though we're
transpiling we'll be able to see our
original code in production we can start
our application with one command when
somebody joins my team you clone the
repository you say npm start and magic
happens and you're seeing your code
there's no special work there we know
that we can run a build that's minified
bundled ready for production by just
saying npm run build and we know that to
get to production you say npm run deploy
all of this is taken for granted and
when you can take all of this stuff for
granted it's awesome because then you
can focus on the hard problems and
programming see this basics this
plumbing that we're talking about here
should not be burning your cycles it
should be a solved problem for your team
and I assert this that the more that we
can take for granted the faster we will
move and the higher the quality we'll be
on our projects so I think of a starter
kit as a living automated and
interactive checklist and increases the
number of things that you can for
granted now a lot of you may feel like
well I kind of have a starter kit I went
out and I used create react app from
Facebook or I use the angular CLI or I
used ember CLI whatever maybe well I
believe that that's not enough my
recommendation to you go find a project
like that for kit make it your own and
then add your opinions in because I
guarantee you your team has a number of
other opinions on top of those tools and
that's precisely what my team has done
we use Create react app behind the
scenes but we have added many many more
opinions on top of it now this is a
really big conversation I published a
five-hour course on Pluralsight called
building a JavaScript development
environment where I talk through all of
those 40 decisions and how you reason
about those but my recommendation to you
is really simple when you get back to
your office on Monday I would suggest
this to you just schedule a meeting
schedule a meeting with your team and
say I want to have a dolt conversation
about the issues let's just sit together
and talk this through and we'll come to
an agreement on how we do JavaScript
here at our company
and I think it'll go well now often
these conversations can get heated
because typescript versus Babel is a big
big deal people feel very very strongly
we've been through this as well but I
don't believe this
I believe if you're having those kinds
of tabs versus spaces conversations on
every JavaScript project you're spending
a lot of time in the wrong place as a
team come together and agree and then
you can move forward so I want to share
another demo I want to show you our
starter kit that we use at Cox
Automotive this is my team starter kit
which we call fusion the way that it
works is you clone the repository just
like you would any other github repo I
already have it cloned over here after
you have cloned it you run NPM run setup
and setup helps you first install all
the packages automatically and after
those packages are installed then it
will prompt you for the settings it will
ask you if you want to delete the git
repository I'm just going to leave it as
is here and then it will prompt you for
your project name as you can see it
enforces a logical name for a
package.json it'll ask you for whatever
version you'd like to assign for the
author of the project it will ask you
for your production URL I'll just put my
URL comm ask you for your license the
project description just a demo and now
that we're done our setup is complete if
I come over to package.json then I can
see that it added this information into
the repository and we have a few scripts
in here to get started the other thing
that's interesting is that our starter
kit has a single NPM package dependency
so we can make changes over time and all
any deployed applications need to do is
pull a new version of fusion and they
get all those bug fixes or new
enhancements in the future now when you
run our starter kit what you will see
what you see is it starts up a demo
application that says welcome to fusion
gives you links to important information
like
our list of reusable components our
style guide and some basic steps that
you can run once you're done looking at
this demo you can run this script to
remove the demo but we also show people
how to work with a Redux app so you can
go behind the scenes and see how this
simple demo application works that just
calculates miles per gallon we show how
our form validation story works in an
interactive way and again you can see
that many of our opinions on forms are
all encapsulated within our reusable
components we show how our mock API
works so you can actually come into here
and save your changes and when you save
those changes you'll see that they're
reflected even when you reload the page
we show how to dynamically import
libraries and we also show how to lazy
load heavy react components you can see
that this loaded after the fact now once
I'm done and comfortable with this demo
I can go ahead and remove it and get
started coding to do that I come over
here and say NPM run remove demo and
when I do we can see that there's a lot
fewer files over here now and if I rerun
the application now it's simply a hello
world so we have a simple starting point
that is ready to run the app so that's
how we do development on my team the
nice thing is everybody knows that they
start with Fusion starters what we've
called it one thing I will recommend is
choose a brand name for whatever you do
I was recently out in San Jose
consulting a team that went for the same
model and they chose their own special
name they called theirs preamp because
they have a model where they're tied to
videos and they like that idea of a
preamp it went well with their branding
had their own logo and everything now
unfortunately what I just showed you
isn't open source so you can't go out
there and dig through it for more but a
very very similar project that I
published about a year and half ago was
reactive slingshot so if you want to dig
through the code and see how all this
works
check out react slingshot just yesterday
it hit seven thousand stars so I was
pretty excited about that it's gotten a
lot of usage so I'm excited about this
this is an opinionated way to work with
react that said I'm a big fan of create
react app too it's a awesome solution so
question how many of you will say that
my team are
bini has its own JavaScript starter kit
Wow
so that is four percent not five four
I'm that exact with my counter so that
is a very very small number so again
look around the room the future is here
it's just not evenly distributed I
believe that this is the future because
starting with final new project is just
too much work and your team has a large
set of opinions there are over 40
decisions that you need to make when you
file new project on JavaScript today and
a starter kit operates as an automated
checklist for your team so that you can
codify your opinions and automate all
the fatigue that people talk about away
my team is not fatigued anymore we know
when we start a project that's what it
looks like and it just works we don't
have conversations about the basics
anymore
all right so we have talked about two of
the three reusable resolutions packages
and starter kits I'm going to close out
this talk with the final revolution
which is reusable components all of
these build upon one another now for
those that aren't familiar with
reasonable components it's a reusable
piece of HTML Javascript and CSS and we
know that these are the big reasons that
we want consistency less code faster
development fewer bugs the component
model gives us these obvious benefits at
Facebook they are heavily invested in
the component model using react and they
find that components helped hundreds of
engineers work on the same codebase move
between teams quickly ramp up and focus
on products now this has happened all
over the world I'm an I'm a car guy I
work for an automotive software company
in fact back in Kansas City and you look
at this Mercedes this is a beautiful car
and you think okay these are a bunch of
special parts inside but in actuality
there's all sorts of reusable pieces
reusable components inside here the seat
belt the button on the seat belt the
airbag systems the transmissions the but
the engines themselves in many cases are
used across vehicles really large
complicated components and this cuts
their costs at speeds development and
increases economies of scale as
developers we have all this same power
now we should be working with higher and
higher level abstractions with better
components as time goes on that's
precisely what's happening on my team
now we've created our basic component
and now we're starting to build on top
of those basic building blocks I will
tell you this I believe that the future
of development is going to be assembling
finished components taking those
components putting them together in
novel ways we'll be thinking of
ourselves more like working with LEGO
pieces rather than having to build the
Legos ourselves leverage higher pieces
higher levels of abstraction now I wish
I could claim this slide but I love how
this slide encapsulates the mindset
shift that you need to make today as a
JavaScript developer for the longest
time we've talked about separation of
concerns as a separation of JavaScript
HTML and CSS I don't believe that's a
valid way to think about separation of
concerns anymore because separation of
concerns today is a matter of components
so I want to separate my concern of this
button from my concern of a date picker
from my concern of this modal dialogue
the component is the concern we're
separating it's a powerful idea because
you recognize that HTML and JavaScript
were never separated concerns we thought
they were back in the jQuery days I
would write unobtrusive javascript
here's my HTML here's my JavaScript the
problem was if I ever changed my HTML I
broke my application if I didn't also
update my JavaScript because my
JavaScript was hard-coded expecting a
certain Dom to be there this is the
important future for JavaScript
developers is thinking about concerns in
terms of reusable components and those
components may be composed of multiple
technologies but separating technologies
doesn't necessarily separate concerns
HTML and JavaScript are fundamentally
intertwined now there's an interesting
question someone might ask you though if
I asked you hey can you share this HTML
with me that's a surprisingly hard
question to answer
I don't know quite how I respond to it
I love I will tell you this is the
hardest thing about writing talks is
getting distracted by stock photography
and all the silliness that you see you
guys couldn't turn the monitor on before
you pointed at it yeah but this is a
hard question can you share this HTML
with me and the really the answer is we
don't share raw HTML what we share
instead is JavaScript that embeds HTML
so if I want to share this div
with you the way that I'm going to get
it done is with JavaScript and this has
been the case throughout history over
the years we've seen a lot of ways to
get this done and this brings us to the
third and final revolution which
actually occurred earlier but I'm
introducing it last for specific reason
that I'll explain in a moment now what
happened
on this date in 2006 no guesses web
components nope that was later Gmail web
app that's an interesting guess no
although that's that's close that was
that was in the ballpark jQuery there we
go yes jQuery was launched in 2006 this
was a very big deal this this is what
kept me from ragequitting web
development I was just about done with
it because cross-browser was so painful
and jQuery wasn't really about
components jQuery was about paving over
inconsistencies in the Dom and giving
you a really elegant API but very
shortly after jQuery came about we saw
this jQuery plugins and jQuery plugins
were really the first popular way to
build reusable components for the web
however today you're likely not going to
reach for jQuery plugins to get this
done today we're all asking ourselves
how should I build components now I
obviously have an opinion on this matter
and in fact I'm going to go ahead and
share it but I want caveat why I believe
that strong opinions are useful for
others those who are undecided or
ambivalent can just adopt your stance
but those who disagree can solidify
their stance by arguing against yours so
I would totally encourage you tonight
we're gonna have an after party I'd love
for you to come up and say how I'm a
dummy head and you feel like this other
thing is better that's absolutely fine
I'll share my opinion on this story
right now because there is no really
clear answer web components the web
components standard is a compelling
option to consider here now I'm a big
fan of standardization if you're not
familiar with web components it's this
idea of four core technologies inert
templates put some markup in there and
it just works custom elements where you
can define your own HTML elements shadow
Dom which encapsulates your Styles so
they don't leak out and imports being
able to bundle HTML Javascript and CSS
now I'm a big fan of standards and I
even created a course on html5 web
components on Pluralsight because I was
really amped about this standard
sad news is I can't stand up here and
push you you might think that that's
what I'm going to tell you right now is
go ahead go use web components but the
story really isn't that simple there's a
few reasons that I'm not reaching for
web components and many of you how many
of you are using native web components
one hand one hand out of I don't know
how many that's definitely a less than
one percent here's why
spotty browser support so you have to
pull in polyfills in those polyfills way
a substantial amount yesterday I just
learned I believe it was 27 K minified
for the polyfills that you need for IE
11 for instance to be able to run the
standard and that's because of browser
support see the template tag is pretty
well supported cross browser except for
IE you'll need a polyfill there but the
other three core technologies not so
HTML imports a lot of read custom
elements shadow dom and we have been
waiting i've literally been waiting for
years for browsers to implement these
standards and we're still waiting so the
question is when there are two other
issues here this at the time I was
really excited about web components
because it enabled some new things the
idea of the shadow Dom was really novel
that I could write simple CSS selectors
and not worry about leaking on to other
components but today javascript
libraries they keep on innovating so in
fact I compared to react for instance
react has answers to all these things
JSX for templates react components are
effectively your custom element you can
use CSS modules or CSS and j/s to keep
your Styles tied to that one component
and we're all using bundlers and npm
anyway so we don't really need the HTML
import specification so my take on it is
this don't wait around for the web
standard to catch on instead just
embrace modern JavaScript the real
question is which framework so these are
the four most popular although there are
many more options out there that I'm not
going to try to fit on a slide here's
what I think you should be asking
yourself though for things how stable is
it how broadly is it adopted how much
boilerplate am I putting in here that's
specific to this library that's gonna
make it hard to shift to something else
later and how much does it weigh so I'm
a big fan of react I'll be completely
honest about that
let's see how it scores here we react
you do code mods when there's a code
change a major release I just run a code
mod that automates it for me and that's
because Facebook has to do that they are
dogfooding in a way that no one else can
compare to facebook.com/ one of the
biggest sites in the world uses 30,000
react components so Facebook can't
afford to make a big braking change that
requires manual changes
they'd have to update 30,000 components
fundamentally react is a function that
returns HTML it is very low boilerplate
and finally it's quite lightweight 43k
gzipped now I may change my mind
tomorrow and if you go see me talking at
conferences on videos from previous
years you'll find I've had different
stickers on my laptop from year to year
this is how my trajectory has been
through history I was using angular not
that long ago but now I'm enjoying react
at the moment next year I may be
somewhere else so you do have to ask
yourself this what if I choose X and
everybody moves to Y whether regardless
of where you are chances are there's
going to be some other new hotness
coming soon my take on it is this if you
choose a low boiler point a low boiler
plate library then you can get started
safely today migration really is
practical see for instance here's react
there's really very little boilerplate
I've got I have an import at the top I
have a function with a name that takes
parameters and it returns HTML if you
told my team hey Cory your team needs to
go rewrite everything in view what you
totally do that that's not a big deal
it's mostly a syntactic change I don't
burn the world to the ground because
really this is what's hard component
design is hard but coding isn't that big
of a deal I'm convinced that my team it
would be relatively straightforward for
us to move to a new technology later
when react is no longer the new hotness
whatever that may be and it may very
well be us moving to standardized web
components once all of the browsers have
really embraced the standard but I don't
believe that you should sit around and
wait because centralized and consistent
is most certainly preferable to
decentralized and inconsistent now
that's not always true but in the
aggregate repeating yourself through
copy and paste is not a design pattern
that scales very well now choosing a
framework is just one of many decisions
that you have to consider here I showed
you something like this when you were
thinking about building a starter kit
there is a similarly ridiculously long
list here and I'm
is going to jump ahead so you don't have
to watch it all go fifty decisions fifty
decisions that you need to consider when
you're going to create a reusable
component library so that is huge again
I went through the same thing I just
published a course if you happen to be
interested in react called creating
reusable react components this is a six
hour course I thought that I could get
it done in two but it is a complicated
conversation because there are this many
decisions to consider fifty different
ones so I want to show you quickly how
we do reusable components at Cox
Automotive this is our documentation for
fusion UI components along the left hand
side we have a alphabetized list of
components I'm looking at the text input
component right now which is an
abstraction over a label a text input
and error message and add some opinions
around that down here we have a list of
examples for each of these examples you
can click on the examples header and see
a snippet of code that you could copy
and paste into an application down at
the bottom we also have a list of props
which you can change to oh I apologize I
hit the trackpad so I will narrate this
anyway just to save us some time
but the thing that I want to emphasize
is one of the harder parts is setting up
your documentation setting it up in a
way that is leveraging all your code and
what we have is all the documentation
that I'm showing you here is generated
from the code we add these comments see
the comments over there on the left it's
kind of a j/s doc style comment that's
what generates our documentation so
every time we hit save in the code we
see our documentation change and that
way we don't have to worry about the two
getting out of sync I show how to get
this done in the Pluralsight course on
react components really the patterns
that I follow would apply just as well
as an angular developer or view
developer don't build your Docs by hand
automate that process so final question
how many of you have your own reusable
component library more hands than I
expected this is great that's probably
15% of the room that's pretty cool
excellent how many of you are working in
angular for that reusable component
library okay how many in react okay how
many of you any Wow so view and reactor
neck-and-neck here that's very different
than kids well I'll find out Kansas City
next
month to KCDC we'll see how much that is
shifted I know view is getting a lot of
attention okay so very very interesting
so we just saw that again everybody with
their hands raised that's an interesting
take as we've gone through this
progression fewer and fewer people are
through these three revolutions because
one revolution builds on another so
let's go ahead and wrap up I want to
clarify why I laid all of this talk out
and the order that I did when you're
gonna build a house with components are
gonna go out and get a chimney component
a door a window these sorts of things
you want to you don't want to start from
scratch and build your own window or
your own door and this should be the
story now today with your development
story on your team but to be able to do
this you need a foundation a house can't
float in the air the foundation that I'm
suggesting for you is a starter kit that
starter kit encapsulates all the
dependencies that your team needs and of
course that starter kit gets hosted on
NPM and that's precisely why I laid out
the reusable revolution in the order
that I did so if you're one of those
people that likes to take pictures of
slides at conferences your big chance
just make sure your camera's not pointed
at your face
first was the NPM packages so the
reusable revolution of packages my call
to you is create your first package we
just saw about 30% of the room has not
created an NPM package before so that's
a big first step in fact no I take that
back it was more like 60% of the room
but not starter kits my call to you is
codify your decisions set up a meeting
on Monday to say let's come to an
agreement as a team here's how we do
lending here's how we do bundling here's
how we do transpiling
etc automate the pain away and finally
with comes to reusable components go
pick a library and start sharing set up
a centralized site and start documenting
your work so if you're gonna take a
picture here's your big chance right
here so hopefully I've shared a vision
that gets you as excited as I am I come
into work each day and I'm just awesome
I'm ready to go I am amped to be a
JavaScript developer I really life is
pretty good for us right now there's
this reusable revolution is taking off I
am HealthCorps on Twitter I'd love a
tweet of feedback thank you all for
listening
[Applause]
[Music]